e
right folks welcome to our uh session of
state federal veterans today we always
start on time because we have uh this is
veterans committee um but we have one
member who is uh just parking and as a
courtesy to that member will hold off on
the pledge just a couple minutes to uh
let him get here since he came all the
way from hookit so we'll be starting in
minutes
time no
you
and I understand you're the smartest uh
daughter
on I told Christina we don't expect much
controversy today so I'm trying to
create some but uh we're still waiting
levit
e
right uh welcome represent L thank you
see
um we heard there was some there was
some um trouble out there all right at
this time uh representative uh lungren
uh Dr lren uh who did did such a
pledge
we will call this uh session of state
federal veterans uh to order at this
time uh we just have the one measure uh
before we go to that measure I do want
to thank the subs who came in
um are yeah who you subing
fores
to is that represent Gallagher
yeah and
[Music]
name
okay as I was saying I want to thank our
subs for for coming today for just the
one measure Gallagher just came in
representative Shu welcome
representative uh Connie Lane has been
here before thank you representative
Lane and representative Jones I saw
welcome uh to you as
well uh a couple of quick housekeeping
things uh FYI uh the last time we met we
did kind of uh I I don't want to say
hurried through but we got through uh
and pasted uh SP 317 that was with
regard to the trade agreement with New
Hampshire and Ireland and FYI the
governor did sign that yesterday just in
time for St Patrick's
Day so uh one of our bills that we have
move to has already been signed into law
and hopefully there will be others
before the end of the
year um we we have the one interim study
Mo measure that's uh h b 1041 that is
the one with regard to the USS
Liberty uh represent Manion has agreed
to chair uh a subcommittee uh on that so
we will need to and I've talked to a
couple people already about possibly
serving on the interim study committee
uh with repres representative Manion uh
maybe before we all leave today we can
uh nail down who else uh uh will'll work
with you on that subcommittee the the
one interim study subcommittee again on
HB
1041 uh I do not know yet
uh how many if any uh Senate bills will
come to us last year I think we had just
one or two um so I I can't tell you yet
uh if we don't get any then uh this
would be our last U our last session I I
suspect there'll probably be uh a couple
but I I do not know that
yet okay at this time um we have the one
measure which is uh house resolution 31
uh representative Manning I'm will'll
motion I motion to uh amend uh what is
this uh 05 99h to the house resolution
31 okay so we're talking about hr31 and
you're uh introducing an amendment to
hr31 okay do we have a second for
representative gagy seconds that uh
repres man would you like to speak to
your amendment to hr31 yeah so the
language came from the the prime sponsor
it was mostly the the entire amendment
is uh replacing just the references to
the the name of the act that this
resolution is for it changes it to
design patent term extension act from
the dignity through Prosperity act
because the actual name is the design
a thank you re gagy um yes I don't
believe we've had yet so I don't think
it's appropriate to introduce the
amendment yet so our exec at yes you're
correct thank you Christina yes
according to schedule uh although
representative Sweeny and the
constituent that he put this measure in
for uh have been here in the past we
were not able to uh officially formally
have the hearing uh he had he could not
be here the first time and then
something came up the second time thank
you Christina so according to the
calendar our hearing um is which I
convened with with my gavl uh was slated
for 1 p.m. so uh we're going to have to
backtrack uh we'll have to have you
reintroduce that once I close the
hearing um and are are there any pink
cars is there anyone here who would like
hr31 seeing none and seeing no pink
cards I
will close the hearing the one the 1 pm
hearing on
hr31 and at this time uh go we will go
to Executive session uh representative
Sherlock thank you Mr chairman just a
couple of points first of all the
amendment is just for the record is
amendment 05
99h that has replaced the original Bill
the other question I have Mr chairman is
the fact that uh what the bill is asking
us to do is to notify our Congressional
uh delegation to support the design
patent term extension act which is
before Congress at this time are all the
where res as we see in this amendment
does that include the entire act or are
the other P parts of the act that we
haven't
seen thank you for the question
representative sherff I honestly have
not read the design patent term
extension act it's uh as you mentioned
is in
Congress uh and again the the last on
line 24 the last part of it does say it
directs should this pass uh it we the
resolution calls for Our House of
Representatives to direct our federal
delegation to actively support and
advocate for the passage of the
uh uh design patent term extension
act so I have not uh honestly read that
whole act I'm my focus our Focus was on
the part of it to support representative
Sweeny's constituent um what what what
are your thoughts well I just point out
Mr chairman I I have
all the faith in the world and
representative Sweeney and what he's
presenting to this committee my only
concern is if there be something is part
of that act we're asking our delegation
to support the entire bill that's coming
before Congress and we don't know what
else might be in there it could be
something that uh would not be in the
best interest of the New Hampshire house
that is my only concern I wanted to
bring it to the attention of the chair
thank you representative I that's a good
point and a fair concern uh my my
response would be were this to pass and
if there was something in the the
federal act that's uh in consideration
in Washington if if any members of our
federal
delegation uh saw anything untour or
something they could not support in the
act and they uh obviously I would trust
that they would uh vote the way they
needed to vote and if they ended up
voting against it then they vote against
it yeah thank you thank you uh it
representative
Jones thank you uh I also am not
familiar with the bill but can I ask is
is the actual purpose of the bill or
maybe the constituent who sent it
Forward would know is it it's just to
help competition on patented uh meds
right is that correct uh thank you for
the question I I read the original and I
uh candidly very frankly I did not fully
understand the intent of it which is why
I pressed Senator s
or Senator Sweeney uh representative
Sweeny to uh help us to
clarify the intent I was hoping he would
be here today I and he had to be
elsewhere so in his absence uh I will
say that he was here with this is a
constituent uh inspired resolution and
he was here with a constituent uh
wheelchair abound who had developed or
some improvisation that had that to
assist people uh I don't know if
handicap's the right word but people
with challenges or
whatever so uh in on line 14 it says
whereas the act uh in question the
designed patent term extension act
whereas the act a aligns the protection
of aesthetic non-functional aspects of
useful articles with the principles of
fairness and Equity simple to co similar
to copyright protection uh um my
understanding is that this was a way to
support the the notion
of of uh someone in the handicap
Community who uh came up with an
innovation in in promoting patent
protection for for that
Community thank you for that Clarity I
I'm not sure how much clearer that is
but I I like I said I wish
representative senen was here
representative Manion please it was
explained to so the idea here is that
the uh design patents would be have
their terms extended to be similar in in
line with the current copyright law and
specifically to help those they call it
uh permanent health conditions in the
bill and to help people with that allow
them more financial Independence on the
longer
term right permanent health condition um
is um a euphemism or or it's another way
I as I interpret somebody who is
permanently disabled is that right yeah
someone i s have the hand rep gagy did
you have a hand
up I've been raising my hand for five
minutes oh I I'm so sorry sh uh pleas um
I'll be honest with you I I did not know
that there was a proposed amendment and
the language to me is quite different
from the original like you I did not
understand what the original was about
um and even the title is different and
my question is uh do we have a ruling on
whether it's actually Germaine since it
is so different uh it seems that if you
had a hearing on it as a non-gain
Amendment people who were actually
interested in the subject matter of the
amendment might come and testify for
it thank you representative in terms of
the gerain to the uh original uh I I
read both and as as I just said and as
you just reiterated uh I had a hard time
understanding the original which is why
uh I we asked for the amendment and I
there's enough language I I think uh in
comparing the original with the amended
version that that uh I would say that
that it it that Jess is not an
issue well my point is that people
looking at the amendment might be
interested in it probably looking at the
original they would not and nobody none
of the public out there knew about the
amendment right we did uh the amendment
was made available and passed out uh
several weeks ago we didn't have we
weren't able to get to a formal uh uh
hearing SL exec at that time but the the
amendment um the committee has had the
amendment for several
weeks and we made copies again today
just as U as a
courtesy um Mr chairman rip some G uh
there's a up but I don't want to miss uh
representative
Lane uh thank
you I Googled design patent term
extension act and nothing comes up which
gives me some concern and I was
wondering if perhaps Our Miss Miss
Christine could ass assist us and let us
know not you the other
one our uh and and and if there's a site
that we could at least read the act
before I vote on it I like okay I like
representative um shirtliff I'm a little
uncomfortable about voting for something
that I haven't
read yeah thank you representative Lane
as I said represent Shir a very fair
question if uh if our researcher
Christina is able to find the uh design
patent term extension act uh if it is uh
100 Pages or so we may we we may have a
recess uh don't laugh
we we uh and if we are unable to find it
then you know occasionally uh there are
those uh uh slight leaps of faith that
we have to
gagy yeah modifying my comment right now
while waiting for um this designed
patent term extension act but the only
substantive change from the original
Bill to the amendment is in the original
Bill line 18 dignity through Prosperity
act and apparently the uh Congress is
has got a bill out which the design
patent term extension act so to me
that's that's the only substantive
change that I see from the original bill
and the
amendment yes I'm comparing the two as
well uh again representative gagy um the
original did refer to the dignity
through Prosperity act um in
representative Lan when you did and
thank you for your due diligence uh so
you Googled design patent term extension
act which is in the amendment and uh and
I uh I know Chris our design or or
designer or a researcher is uh is
following up looking U for the design
patent term extension act
um I uh I could pull out my device and
Google dignity through Pro uh Prosperity
act uh ripson Lane you Google design
patent term extension act right I did
digity oh and ation stat okay okay so
that explains why there was there was
some questions about immigration someone
um had Googled the original okay so
explain uh yes represent Lloyd sorry I
um got stuck in traffic so this may have
already been covered I assume this was
brought up because of the fact that uh
people who are on disability are
generally um it's hard to find work
because they cannot work um and that's
why they qualify for disability so this
would allow a person to have income
coming in from the uh from what I'm
understanding from the um selling of
their designs or patents um okay thank
you yes Tron man you were shaking your
head do you want to uh speak to that no
she had the nail on the head that's
exactly how it was explained to me yes
and again uh representative Sweeny and
his constituent were here earlier uh and
I I was able to uh speak to them briefly
gentleman was was wheelchair bound and
and um I don't want to say he was an
inventor but he uh had uh come up with
some sort of uh creation that fell into
copyright patent uh uh issues so to
speak
and I again my interpretation of the
intent of the uh sponsor was to uh
support uh folks in his situation and
condition getting uh Fair consideration
for patent
extensions uh yes represent C trying to
like word this correctly um I guess what
I'm saying is is
that when it comes to getting a patent
this would it's not it's less about an
extension of a current patent it's about
them getting a patent but if they didn't
apply for it
first this would give them preferential
treatment essentially because of the
their disability
or I wouldn't uh thank you for your
common question uh I don't see that as
preferential treatment as I read this I
see it as a a a request or a resolution
promoting fair fair treatment as opposed
to preferential uh is and repr Manion uh
I know you introduced I would say so
because the idea here is that there's a
conflict between like you have copyright
that lasts like what whatever Disney's
thing was where it was like aund
something years and then you have like
design patents for like creative
components of of whatever the hell is
being designed and that has a much
shorter life lifespan even though you
there should be some kind of unification
here like at least they should be
treated the same with the same
timetables
ripson Lloyd well I kind of uh I I guess
the biggest question I would have thank
you Mr chairman by the way um the the
biggest question that I would have uh
with this is are is this for new patents
being um submitted or is this for
continuing and ongoing patent if it's
continuing and ongoing patent then the
work for that patent would have happened
prior potentially to this person's
disability um to be able to be to
continue earning off of that patent in
my opinion but thank you for the
question uh is in terms of if this
applies to a new patent situation or an
ongoing uh ranion we in the whereas
Clause uh the amended in the amended
version uh it does say extend the
lifetime design patent terms to
individuals yeah so it it it would give
them longer extend
existing does that kind of speak to your
question uh represent sh thank you I did
look this up and I found uh the US code
site for the U design patent term
extension act and it appears that what
this is addressing would be a proposed
amendment to that okay extending the
time that's my impression because it
does exist in federal law already uh us
code 35 section
154 uh through I think it's 156
so this if it already exists I'm
guessing that this is proposing or
addressing a proposal to amend the
existing code and I don't know how you
find the amendment that's being proposed
doing yeah thank you represent Shu uh
and I really appreciate especially as a
substitute that you take the time to to
do some of this due diligence and same
of Representative Lane um again my My
Hope had been that the sponsor would be
here uh and I'm leaning heavily on poor
representative Manion who introduced the
uh the proposed amendment um I want to
take I have a thought or two that I'll
share later once if if anyone else has a
question or a comment I know um uh
any
weon
Galler so um as a substitute I'd just
like to note that um in my home
committee at least Municipal and County
government we just kind of on General
principle vote itl on any um Bill where
the prime sponsor doesn't show up to
introduce it to us um because precisely
because of situations like this where
people end up having a lot of questions
that really only the prime sponsor would
be capable of answering adequately due
to you know it really being
like really figuring out what his intent
was here with it like I I don't think
any of us can adequately answer that
question for
him yeah thank you repon of gallager uh
I have to point out this is not a bill
this is a
resolution uh yes and some of you may
recall this was initially scheduled and
the uh Prime sponsor asked that it be
rescheduled because he was unable to be
here and we weren't able to work it in
to schedule wise to a subsequent session
uh which is why we have the hearing and
and now the exec session on this today
um I have a couple thoughts but thank
you for that um but I want to see if
anyone else has any uh yes
representative
Jones thank you Mr chair may I ask your
researcher a question sure receed thank
you um is is there's I believe there's
something in there that says this only
deals with pre-market patent approval so
that was my question when you mentioned
print out uh how how big was it was it
have to be or or uh seeing you're right
on that would you be able to uh uh
paraphrase or or
summarize the uh the essence of
it sure sure uh again that that's a a
good fair question other questions
comments yes uh
gagy right now I feel like a sailor on
ship who's just lost all Communications
lost
steering and my GPS is not working
and you know I I listen to
representative Gallagher's comments it's
a good comment um however if it comes to
the point where I still can't make up my
mind I would probably recommend
something like interum study and give it
a a soft Landing so to
speak yes thank you representative gagy
um was that a motion
we we we have a motion on on the floor
to on the amendment uh while uh
Christina is looking for some more
information um I I have a thought or two
but again I want to make sure that I
don't pass over anyone
um so uh my thought on this uh or
thoughts are as follows again uh very
important this as I mentioned to
represent Gallagher this is not a not a
bill would be very if this was proposed
statute we definitely would not move
anything forward uh without some
amplification from the prime sponsor uh
this is a resolution and I have met the
uh it's and most of us have probably all
of us have had constituent requests for
different types of support I put in a
number of bills and resolutions for
constituents um of varying types and we
want to support obviously our
constituents when we can with uh by
introducing bills or resolutions which
is what uh representative Sweeny did
here and I did meet the constitu in
question um as I've already said several
times I I had a hard time understanding
the original and uh the amendment um I
am understanding better uh essentially
what this comes down to is uh a
legislator uh put a resolution in to
support a handicapped if I can use that
word uh different cons uh different Le
right uh cons
constituent and uh thank you for I
didn't anticipate all questions and
these are all good questions that's why
we're here
um on this resolution the way that I and
I'll figure out how I'm going to vote
shortly the way I look at it the way I
feel about it is I'm inclined to support
uh the intent and to support the
resolution it's not a Bill's
resolution uh aimed at supporting a uh
uh a
handicapped um
constituent now uh representative
shift's question it was an excellent
question uh if it and we've already
addressed that I've spoken to that in
that this directs our federal delegation
to actively support and advocate for the
passage of this congressional act that
is looking into um as I said to the
representative from
Penacook um that does that's if
something were to come out that was
unored then the federal delegation
certainly as I said earlier could uh not
support it that would be
fine um I cons the way that I would see
this moving forward and again I we'll
vote on it on the amendment and
um would be to have this move forward
have the resolution move forward and
then uh before it comes to the uh Full
House in in in two weeks uh the prime
sponsor could uh address and would
address and I would ask him to address
uh all any and all questions and if uh
if he he cannot answer the questions to
our our satisfaction to include the subs
who who are here today have Tak taking
time to work on this then we could vote
it down in the house
um whereas if we you you know
itl this this type of resolution um that
uh that kind of hurts my heart a little
bit uh given the intent of this this is
not like a climate resolution it's it's
you know it's it's uh for uh one
constituent need that's how I see it um
Mr chair uh represent Jones say you saw
your
hand thank you Mr chair uh for procedure
purposes wouldn't it be okay to do the
amendment because that gives it Clarity
on what the on what the actual bill is
where we're having a problem but that
would put the wording in that we need
and then from there we could take the
amended resolution and do OTP
itl uh intermittent or whatever way you
want to do it tabling
thank you represent represent good point
we have a motion on the floor representa
shart yes U procedurally you would have
another alternative uh if it comes to
the floor in two weeks you could still
move to recommit it to committee and
then perhaps have it come back and do
interim study or something rather than
actually kill
it yes I thank you we were looking to
recommit a a measure earlyer
uh there's a timeline in terms of
getting if it is recommitted uh to
reconvene this this committee for this
one
resolution Uh I that would not be my
first choice given the nature of the
resolution and and everybody's time uh
that you know to to do this again for
this uh seems like to me seems like a
lot of time and effort and expense uh
that I would want to avoid if I could it
for this is my thoughts are if this was
a bill or or a high-profile re
resolution um that would be easier to do
that
than something given the nature of this
so uh represent uh Lloyd sorry one more
question uh before we would make any uh
potential movements on these H has
anybody from Americans with Disabilities
wait in on this at all um because I know
that they tend to prefer to have some
sort of say and have a seat kind of at
the table in order to understand better
the situation going
on yeah thank you for the question uh I
have received we have received nothing
from um any lobbyist or anyone from any
organization and I know that the uh
there are the lobbyist folks PE people
look at every single uh thing that LSR
you know these are all scrutinized very
closely now maybe they did and they
[Music]
but red light please I'm just saying
from the original bill they probably
wouldn't even known it applied to them
or their their people yes I
sherff the the I I understand what
you're saying about this is a resolu
ution as opposed to a bill my only
concern is that last paragraph where
this this committee is uh strongly
saying they strongly support this
amendment and they strongly urge our
legisl legislators from New Hampshire
and Co and Congress to Advocate Advocate
on the passage of this bill and you had
mentioned about having representative
Sweeney come to the floor if there's a
question why would it be possible for
this committee to do the reverse and
only because of our concerns we've
expressed about this to do as my friend
from Manchester suggested move in um uh
to interim study and if representative
Sweeney wants to bring a floor amendment
to change it and then answer our
questions that we have now then I would
have no problem vot on the floor when we
next
meet uh thank you Mr Speaker ameritus so
uh you procedurally we this
to be recommended for interim study uh
before this comes to the floor if if the
questions that have come up can be
answered can
the interim study recommendation be
changed
uh it can be no well be because
oftentimes uh uh an itl can be rejected
and a subsequent motion of OTP
introduced can an is be rejected uh
representative Lane seems to be agreeing
with
Ved make motion it's open to further
motions okay so uh that was kind of my
question if if we did give this an
interim study went to the floor as such
our questions are answered uh we vote
down interim study and there's a motion
subsequent motion for
OTP uh that process that procedure
sequence could work exactly I would
think if the chair of the committee got
up and explained to the house that you
wanted them to kill the interim study
motion and address the uh proposed
amendment and Bill that would probably
hold a lot of weight I'd prefer that you
would explain it all repr sh it but I
that's my that would be my job
um we've had some very active Subs in
this committee and and we don't we don't
discourage their
participation um so what I'm with the
motion on the floor is the the to uh uh
adopt the amendment
um and then
so let let's vote on the amendment the
the measure as
amended uh and whether to accept the
amendment and then we can have a
subsequent motion of
is OTP
itl uh so I want to if there's no other
hands like to move the question on the
amendment uh and the motion Madame clerk
is on
Amendment um
H so the motion is to amend the measure
with this amendment seconded by
representative gagy
um so on the amendment if you would read
the the role sure representative Rollins
yes representative lungren yes
representative levit I representative
gagy yes representative ponti yes
representative
Manion yes representative shirtliff yes
representative Lane yes representative
Shu yes representative Carrie yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative
Judy
Madame representative Lloyd yes
representative Jones yes representative
Sebert yes and the
chair yes okay one two three four five 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 is that s
right 16 16 to zero so the the amendment
is approved so now uh we're dealing with
the uh amended house resolution with the
amendment that we just approved uh so
now what to do with uh the amended
resolution Mr chairman uh repres would
it be appropriate for me now to make a
motion that we move in to move in from
study on this
bill uh you can make a motion uh anytime
no
well trying to be nice to
kind I don't want to be too candid I
don't want to be all that candid but I
would move in from study but I think it
might be better if it came from this
side of the
aisle
for possibly from the from the from the
Democratic side of this
committee uh understood uh so I I can I
sense there's some interest in making a
motion um is there any before we go to
the mo is there
any the motion hasn't been made yet
officially
is there any other thought I just made
it Mr chairman okay is there okay there
is there is a motion okay is and but is
there a second I thought I heard a
second second so the motion is interim
study from representative shirtliff with
a second from representative Lloyd uh
repres Shir would you care to speak to
your
motion thank you Mr chairman uh I think
well I think we've all been here we've
heard the discussion on this bill uh I
think we've got a lot more questions and
answers and I appreciate the C of the
chair and trying to get the solutions as
well as representative Manion for giving
the answers he's given us but I think
the fact that we're not quite sure what
this is about what it entails um it
would be best to inim study and then see
where that goes thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative Sheriff
representative uh
Lloyd um yeah I I absolutely second what
M uh what representative shirtliff said
um that and we have a lot of other
questions about it so
yeah representative
gagy I wholeheartedly agree with my
colleague on the other side of you there
that a fellow student at the police
academy
1970 was 12
then somehow I think I've heard that
before uh hear it again too other
comments on the motion of interim
study seeing no other
hands uh when you're ready Madam clerk
uh the motion is in Rim study on HR 31
as amended okay representative Rollins
yes representative lungren yes
representative levit right
representative gagy yes representative
Pimon thanks
for yes representative Manion yes
representative shirtliff yes
representative Lane yes representative
sh
yes representative Carrie yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative
Judy and representative Lloyd yes
representative Jones yes representative
Sebert yes and the chair yes okay so
that's 16 to nothing
again I Mo
consent uh okay with regard to consent
if if the scenario discussed comes up
where we want uh after communicating
with the prime sponsor if if the we want
to yeah I I don't I'm sorry I didn't
mean to interrupt you Mr chairman I just
say that he could pull it off consent
but if you'd rather have it on the
regular calendar that's not a problem I
would I think we would I would have it
on the regular calendar and then uh we
can quickly dispatch it one way or the
other I withdraw my motion
okay
160 160 yep uh and that's all we have uh
is just I thought this would take just a
few minutes and uh with with thank you
for your good questions and your due
diligence and now I I have some work to
do with the prime sponsor uh before we
close anything from anyone on uh on any
committee
uh wanted to be on oh yeah yes uh thank
you represent Manion um so on
uh I'd like to have at least three or
more Folks at least three uh a couple
others to work with repres man represent
uh gy I mentioned it to you you're a
Navy
may
um so representative gagy uh is going to
try to find time for at least one
meeting representative Sher I know I
mentioned to you you'd mentioned
represent Massa might be interested
she's
here uh she's not here but uh I have no
problem volunteering her
okay so rep representative massamilla
has been volunteered by representative
sheriff and then appointed by the chair
so so represent may you have you have
three names would anyone else like to to
work on this uh uh Ron Lloyd oh good uh
as so representative Lloyd uh as well
and uh the chair is always ex officiate
on these things so we have you have uh
four four of you all okay uh thank you
representative
Lloyd uh all right at this time uh the
exec session is uh is over and thank you
it
e